a person's capabilities are limited and
there are there are things that we can
do better than computers but if you want
to do them in scale and like
scan and search from a variety of
opportunities it's very very hard to do
it when you are limited so this i think
the part that technology really helps
because it helps you
map map all the noise and find the right
opportunities that are suitable to your
investment process
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders here at google for startups i'm
with sapir khadad the co-founder and ceo
of phoenix talking all about investing
and how deep technology can help disrupt
investment behavior ultimately to help
all of us make better financial
decisions
sapira was born and raised in ashkelon
and is currently living in tel aviv she
is the co-founder and ceo of phoenitics
a deep tech startup developing ai
solutions for investment professionals
phoenix helps investors implement ai
tools as part of their investment
process to save time and resources and
improve
quality i'm really excited to talk to
you about your own journey about phoenix
about the financial markets about
leveraging
really really interesting technology to
rethink about investments and how we
perceive financial markets how we make
decisions in financial markets exactly
you know this is a century-old question
that people are uncovering
and i'm excited to hear about how you're
perceiving technology playing an
interesting role in your role as an
entrepreneur in this space
and you're the ceo of phoenix tell me a
little bit about
sort of financial markets from your
perspective
why why is it even something that you're
so curious about okay so
the reason i got interested in financial
markets was basically because of my
co-founder gal
i wasn't into investments at all
as i grew i grew up in ashkelon we
didn't even know
about investing no one ever talked to me
about it it was something like that
always scared me but then i met gal
during my studies we studied together
economics and big data and he invest
since he was 13 he got basically got his
balmisfa money and started investing the
stock market
and it shocked me like i was amazed from
it and we started talking during our
studies and he started explaining me
about this word i was always always
passionate about the economics but not
really doing investing like the the
macro like understanding uh the system
but i really never
try to invest in the system and to
understand how the investment process
is working and then i think that you're
you're describing here probably the same
phenomena that most people around the
world exactly so so and so what how do
we capture that is it a lack of
transparency
the complexity of it
why is it that people don't really get
into it
first of all i i think uh if we like
simplify it it's an investment it's a
decision-making process everyone makes
uh decision-making in their day-to-day
life it's not something that we're not
familiar with but i think that there is
like
education that we need to educate people
to invest in their future because once
they invest in the stock market or in
any other investment it doesn't have to
be specifically the stock market crypto
any other investment
they basically invest in themselves like
in themselves when they're grown and i
think that's something that
people don't really talk about and for
example in my family uh no one
talked to me about
investing your money my money was
in my bank account i always worked since
i was 14 but i never thought about doing
something with the money and i think
it's just like bringing awareness
and also it's very very hard to do
investments if you don't have the right
tools or if you don't work at it because
if you don't work it's a lot of
work to research and to find the right
opportunities and there is a lot of the
data inflation and a lot of big
companies that you compete with and
time is everything and you need to find
the right opportunities and so it's very
very hard because you need to work on it
but i think that there are other
solutions like passive investment that
you just invest even in in a
benchmarking etf you don't even
need to invest actively that can bring a
solution so people don't really know
that those solutions are are existing so
i think
it's awareness will will help
uh bring more people to the table and
you see a lot of retail uh investors
like
coming into this uh to this area because
they just they start feeling like okay
wait i'm missing something everyone is
doing money making money no matter that
most of them are losing the money but
everyone talks about
okay we make money we make money and so
now it's i feel like this the gen z and
the millennials are trying are starting
to to like wake up and to understand
that it is something important
uh but
when i grew up no one talked with me
about it so
gal exposed me to it and i was like
okay i gotta learn more about it and i i
need to understand what is this
investment process what does it takes
and we started researching it took us
like
three years before we founded phoenix
during our studies so we just talked
with every
analyst portfolio manager
quant in israel in the states wherever
we could find and we just asked them how
do you do the investment process which
tools do you use what
is your intuition what's part is like
pure science and we started the
understanding that
there is like a process there is uh
everyone does it in different ways but
you have like at the end it starts with
the idea and it ends with execution sure
and this entire process has so many
parts and each one does it differently
but the thing that we we noticed the
most that
only like 10 from the people that we've
talked with which is more than hundreds
like yes more than hundreds
use technology
in this process and that was like and
obviously just using excel or something
that's not technology that's not
technology when we're looking technology
we're saying some something that gives
us insight that we wouldn't have exactly
inputting ourselves yes exactly
and then we saw that really there are
companies uh like two sigma aqr
renaissance that they're using
technology like fast in their entire
process and they're outperforming the
market but all the rest are like using
uh
some small tools or not knowing exactly
how to fit the technology to their pain
and so they can't really outperform
the previous results so they say okay so
it it doesn't work it's better if i'll
do it myself would excel and so they
just
leave it on the side and they don't use
it but i think
that with the right technology
and and understanding the right pain of
these investment managers and quant
teams you can really find the right
solution for them that will help them
enhance their investment process and
improve
their quality
amazing so so going to the formation of
phoenix you're realizing the pain point
which from my understanding is that
there's two problems first there's the
initial problem that people don't invest
right it's just
it's not that common of an idea and it
doesn't sound like it's a taboo subject
it sounds like it's just something
that's a little bit more complicated
more cumbersome
it sounds a little scary because there's
a lot of different options and we know
from that
when there's a lot of options we often
freeze and we don't make any decision
on the other hand those that do invest
they're not leveraging necessarily
technology that can provide them
insights that they don't have otherwise
and so on both paradigms were lacking
exactly now at that intersection
how do you envision technology being
able to be an aid in investments and how
does this play into phinetix's product
okay so
first of all it took us three years to
develop our product we're a team of
four algorithm developers three big data
engineers we have some investment
professionals that like helped us along
the way but the solutions that we offer
are
mainly mainly mainly technological and
data-driven and i think this is the
first thing that helps
generating those solutions uh because
you need to to look at outside the
system in order to create something that
could really help the system sometimes
when you're inside you're like
on it you can't see what is outside
and our solution is basically
it's taking technology is leveraging a
lot of new technologies that like for
example deep learning so we didn't have
enough computing powers to use it until
2017 yeah although it's like until the
in the 70s yeah people already used it
already knew about it but we didn't have
enough computing powers and now with the
power of deep learning we can
really do
some amazing tools and also systems that
can help in the process so
the point is that we really mapped the
entire investment process and we've
divided it into parts so you have the
hypothesis and the idea that this
belongs to the professional we don't
take that they know what they're doing
but the rest the execution
we want to take part and we want to
enhance it with technology so
if it's the
portfolio building the location the risk
management uh the hedging everything
until deployment we want to take part
that chooses technology because at the
end
a person's capabilities are limited and
there are there are things that we can
do better than computers but if you want
to do them in scale and like
scan and search from a variety of
opportunities it's very very hard to do
it when you are limited so
this i think the part that technology
really helps because it helps you
map map all the noise and find the right
opportunities that are suitable to your
investment process because not
everything is suitable to you because if
you want to invest
only in technology sector you wouldn't
mind what's going on in other sectors so
you need to be
really specific in what you want and i
think that technology can help you bring
specific solutions to what you want
right and so what is the actual
experience that a that some users may
have with finitex so what are what is
sort of the human computer interaction
here let's say that i'm interested in
investing okay so currently now we're
working only with b2b companies with
like hatch funds
and also brokers that now we're starting
to work we have a robo advisor company
that we develop some tools to help
retail clients well i have a venture
capital fund so how do i
okay so we have a lot a lot of tools and
it could be we can offer an a to z
solution which means
you give us your hypothesis you say what
is the strategy you would like to build
and we take it from there and just in
two weeks you'll get a fully trained
deep learning model that was trained
based on your preference this is the
first solution
and this is a model that you were built
you built trained and provided me right
yes on my specific use case yes you give
me your risk tolerance i ask you some
execution parts risk management
allocation i ask you several questions
and the idea is that it's a no-code
technology so you you talk to me right
with no call and then a json file goes
to the cloud and start like
getting all the data and doing all the
process and then
what phoenix's does is you have the
engine in the back end exactly take this
json and then being able to create to
train a model specific to my needs
exactly and then what you get at the end
is like a statistical kit with a
historical back test all the results
comparing to the benchmark that you
chose you can see like a stress test
there is a lot of things a lot of data
you can you can see and then you can say
okay i think this model is good i it's
it's my kpis like i approve it and then
you can start all trading on it or
seeing it on paper and then trade on it
so this is the first solution that we
offer like an a to z think of it a
research team sure yeah you bring you
the entire solution you bring your
hypotheses we provide the model and the
rest is just because we've built this
infrastructure it enables us to build a
lot of tools for every part so
if you have uh for example if you would
like to head your portfolio so we have
an auto edging tool so you you'll tell
me okay this is my portfolio i would
like to hedge it uh from inflation
because currently there is inflation or
i would like to hedge it from a specific
uh
risk on the stocks or any other asset
class or like a specific sector and
basically you bring us this uh again
hypothesis of preferences and we provide
you with the tool that helps you and the
idea is that is it is actively managing
and managed so it's not like a passive
we don't give you it one time and then
it always gets the data he can tell you
don't change anything in your portfolio
you can do it but
all the time every time there is a
trading
is giving you his input so you can
decide if you want to use it or not but
it's actively learning getting more data
all the time and you can use it so it's
either a to zed or you can choose any
part of your investment process any part
you have painting in it and we can
provide you a solution so we started the
conversation talking about your personal
experience and going into and meeting
with gal
and hearing his investment store and
you're realizing wow there's a
difference between how i'm perceiving
investments and how you're perceiving
investments and and you choose a more
b2b approach
at least for now for phonetics exactly
what was the decision-making process
between going for b2c so sort of the
superiors of the world
versus more b2b approach like the hedge
funds and the different okay so b2c is
definitely my dream let's say it like
this uh it's what keeps me uh motivated
to do the things i do that's is this the
vision is that the long-term vision
because at the end technology really
helps you enables you
democratization yeah it really helps you
do that yeah and if i have an ai factory
that means that i can really customize
to each person his own
strategy to trade on so this is like the
long term vision but
i think that we really wanted at first
to bring it to the people that are
already using it and already experience
the pain in their own process and then
after and we do try to work with like uh
pokerag films or robo advisors in order
to provide them solutions to to bring
the retail clients but it's definitely
something that now also with the web 3
and nft we do think about like doing
some other solutions for also uh little
clients but uh
step by step i understood that i can't
have it all in one day and it like it
needs to it takes time and it's gonna be
like step by step but it's completely
part of our vision like
investments for everyone so for b2b for
b2c for everyone though so this is like
this is why i get up in the morning
and how will you know that it's time to
do that i mean so
in other words you know as the ceo of
this company setting the vision every
day you're going to have to make this
decision right do i continue with this
course or is this an is this the right
time to now shift gears and to pursue
sort of the the why i'm getting up here
in the morning
do you have some benchmark or how are
you even thinking through your own
personal strategy for knowing when to
make this pretty seismic shift and in
thinking
but i don't think about it as a
as a
shift i do think about it as another uh
business sector and i think that the
right time because it doesn't hurt if i
provide
uh tools for investment managers i don't
provide the same for retail clients sure
so it's different and there is like a
place for everyone the technology
enables that i think the right time and
i'm i'm not gonna sound politically
correct but currently now uh there are a
lot of
apps
that are for retail clients that enable
easy investing
but
basically their business model and the
way they interact with the users with
the ui ux it it's built for them to lose
money and to do as much trades as they
can do like so
they're promoting more investment
behavior that is not necessarily good
for the for the the clients they're not
strategy oriented they're more
trading exactly and i think that now
like in
we will experience it now where like
with the recession and all the things
that are happening in the stock market
i think
uh
it's they're starting to
to the the greater clients are starting
to awaken and to
to want more
like not only is investing it's good
that i have easy investing but i want
now smart investing yeah and currently
now they're still in the same arena
because everyone provides them easy
investing and they don't understand
their motivations
behind what they give them and so
it's really really hard to educate a
market i saw how it's how to educate me
when gal just started talking to me and
i think that the market needs to be more
ready the the retail clients needs to be
more ready for it and once i'll fill i
always check it i do market research on
it
every time as the same as i do for the
b2b i also do for b2c i always check all
the trends what's going on and i think
that when i'll feel that they're ready
it will be the time that i will start
this section and and hopefully at that
point phoenix will have some some
headway with their be with the b2b and
you'll have some fun exactly and then
you'll be able to one day say all right
everybody we're ready exactly let's just
do it and now we have the resources we
have the technology exactly
and and and obviously it will be a very
interesting um
a very interesting approach uh rather
than just starting from scratch
what are you most excited about in your
day
in my day to day the people that i work
with
definitely no doubt i have like a team
that i'm working with almost
four years since i started we're a
strong technological team now we're
adding uh marketing and sales and
another very important parts for our
team but
the other people that makes me come to
work every day and with a smile
i think it's the most important thing
because in the end
i do work for like my vision and to to
achieve my vision but in the day-to-day
you work with people and for the people
so i think it's the most important thing
is that i have them with me like if i
have a bad day and i'm coming back home
and i'm like starting to feel a little
bit anxiety or things like this when i
think about them that are with me i'm
like
okay so everything will be just fine do
you have them you have a winning team it
will be just fine you know that so
that's what excites me the most and the
way they solve
these problems
they really think outside the box and
they really do like execution to other
vision you know in a way that
not me and not god even imagined that it
could be done like this so this is what
really uh keeps me emotional
about this and excites me
yeah yeah thank you so much for this
time thank you for the great work and i
look forward to to using some of the
strategies myself as a consumer and
and i think that you're right i mean the
the way that
the the conversation around investing
today is is so i would even say
primitive in the sense of
the conversation is not really existent
and where it is existent a lot of the
tools i agree they're not necessarily
promoting the right strategies and
taking people in the right approach of
where they want to get to and we see the
chaotic nature of the markets and we see
how volatile it is and at the end this
is people's livelihoods and and there
are some insane statistics about the
lack of funding that that families have
in the united states and the world and
so
this is literally touching people's
lives and so i look forward to seeing
how you enter the b2c market and what's
happening there wait for it
thank you very much for your time great